bonjour l'oni besançon merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
où vous vivez en suède vous connaissez
bien la situation épidémique là bas la
suède qui va donc ré instaurer à partir
du 1er décembre à un pass vaccinale à sa
population alors que les chiffres ne
sont pas si alarmant comment est-ce que
vous l'expliquer bonjour merci non sa
mort oui alors c'est effectivement pour
le non les chiffres mensuels ne sont pas
si dramatique cela dit je pense que
l'épidémiologiste en chef de la suède pu
voir que c'était le cas dans les pays
voisins que savez certainement arriver
au dernier stockholm et de la suède à
très bientôt donc je pense que c'est une
mesure préventive
ce qui fait à peu près sens quand on
voit la situation épidémiologique
ailleurs donc à mon avis c'est juste
plutôt logique c'est une suite assez
logique ce point ci de pousser les
derniers résistants la vaccination je
pense à se vacciner pour éviter les cas
graves et de
débiter la nature engorgement des
animations n'ont alors d'autre décision
c'est celle de tester à nouveau les
personnes vaccinées ce n'était plus le
cas effectivement pourquoi là encore
revenir sur cette décision qui est
critiquée on le fait ça mais ça j'en ai
juste dit hier il me semble c'est
certainement parce que bah c'est ça me
faisait un gros billet dans les chiffres
qui étaient obtenus par le par la suède
puisque si on avait des symptômes a
jusqu'à hier il fallait plus se tester
certaines doublement vacciner ce qui
fait que calais les stades sur les
chiffres sur les quarts en tout cas
était difficile à
apprendre en compte sérieusement
puisqu'on pouvait pas réellement savoir
quelle était la situation globale
puisque on a plus de 70% la population
et qui est vacciné donc pour avoir une
idée claire du nombre de cas en suède
ils ont décidé de rechange et ça ce qui
fait aussi à tout à fait son show oui
c'est ça le problème c'est que à partir
du moment où on est est plus et comment
avoir une une situation réelle de la de
la situation tout à fait un petit peu le
problème voilà c'est tout à fait le
problème est quand on regarde les
chiffres au niveau du danemark on peut
voir que par exemple le danemark test
énormément par rapport à la suède c'est
aussi le cas de la finlande qui était ce
bien plus donc on pouvait toujours se
rapporter aux taux de positivité des
tests mais c'est quand même à mieux de
tester les double vacciner quand même
alors du coup est ce que ces chiffres
sont fiables on parlait de la semaine
comme étant celui où les cas de
contamination étaient les plus faibles
jusqu'à aujourd'hui comment est ce qu'on
peu apprise appréhendé par conséquent
ces chiffres aujourd'hui si on regarde
le taux de positivité du coup avec
probablement un meilleur indice on se
rend compte qu'il est semblable à celui
de ses voisins à
un peu à faire un peu supérieur au
danemark mais donne énormément c'est un
peu difficile de comparer ces deux là il
est fort probable que situation soit à
peu près similaire à celle des voisins
aujourd'hui si on prenait en compte les
double vaccinés avec des symptômes
encore une fois voilà c'est une
estimation c'est très difficile d'avoir
des drm chiffres quand on est à ce titre
un peu et est vous qui à terme un
spécialiste des chiffres alors on prend
en compte le taux de positivité
est ce que c'est vraiment ce chiffre là
qui devrait faire référence est ce que
c'est pas le taux de mortalité
finalement
le taux de natalité est évidemment
important alors avec le vaccin on a on
est sensé de diminuer beaucoup c'est un
petit peu l'idée on diminue les cas
graves on diminue la mortalité le bac ça
marche très bien pour ça il le taux de
positivité chiffres us nous voilà
en suède particulièrement où dans le
monde on se connait simulation
n'ont normalement pas si on regarde
aller les données effectivement les
vaccins fonctionne pour ça c'est comme
ça que la suède a pu éviter d'ailleurs
une quatrième bague à mortels puisque là
elle et ont commencé à saillé toujours
une petit petit décalage dans le temps
des bagues les pays du nord donc il ya
toujours eu leur bac 3 à 4 5 semaines
plus tard que les autres pays d'europe
les plus au sud et donc si on regarde
effectivement ils ont commencé à
vacciner bien avant le début de la
quatrième vague des gens tromper le
reste de l'europe et donc j'invite
évoque clairement un petit et mortalité
acquis le reste de l'europe a connu la
suède qui s'est distinguée aussi dans la
crise du coronavirus par l'absence de
confinement est une stratégie qui repose
est plutôt sur des recommandations
plutôt que c'est sur des obligations est
ce que là encore on voit une différence
et un impact sur les chiffres par
rapport aux autres pays
alors par rapport aux autres pays
d'europe ces défis la peau paraît encore
une fois comparé la suède avec avec la
france ou avec l'espagne l'italie très
difficile icd pays qui sont
culturellement différents et des
densités de population différente avec
une situation sanitaire de départ
différentes donc on peut pas vraiment
les comparer si on compare aux voisins
on voit bien que pale ale l'absence de
mesures a eu un impact sur la mortalité
on voit que la suède sur l'ensemble de
la pandémie avait plus de décès par
million que ses trois voisins manille
quand même à c'est assez dommage
alors après effectivement surtout des
recommandations les recommandations
quand même une espèce de forme
d'obligation légale dans les textes
et surtout je pense que le gouvernement
s'assure le fait que les suédois comme
les danois probablement les finlandais à
elle le norvégien ont tendance à écouter
ce que le gouvernement leur audition
qu'on leur impose nécessairement est on
avec la vaccination et la page de
direction ouest n'a jusque-là pas eu de
cesse vaccinale et lens vacciner quand
même ouais c'est toute la différence
avec la france notamment il n'y a pas eu
d'obligation vaccinale y en a pas
d'emplois en france un peu déguisés mais
il n'y a pas de l'opa sanitaire le fait
que les personnes soient vaccinés on
voit bien de toute façon ça n'empêchera
pas les contaminations donc de toutes
façons les chiffres seront
au niveau des contaminations oui c'est
plutôt logique ça évitera les cas
sévères ça évitera la mortalité ça
diminue légèrement si on regarde les
derniers chiffres des publications ça
diminue très légèrement les
contaminations de toute façon le vaccin
dans sa a été souvent présenté peut-être
de façon assez erronée comme la solution
pour sortir de la crise c'est
effectivement la solution nécessaire il
faut des vaccins mais c'est pas
suffisant c'est comme ça qu'il faut le
prendre réellement non que les mesures
barrières et continue à regarder
quelques-unes porter le masque notamment
ça pourrait être utile bon je pense que
retourner dans déconfinement maintenant
qu'on a un mac c'est peut-être un petit
peu a trop poussé surtout si on arrive à
vacciner à la majorité de la population
mais en tout cas garder le basque faire
attention à l'endroit je recommande pas
essayé de se retrouver à
70,26 l'appartement et probablement de
se sentir ça la suède non plus n'avait
pas imposé lomas car le port du masque
ne s'est pas obligatoire n'ont en effet
c'était c'était uniquement imposé dans
les transports en commun entre 7h et 9h
enfin les soeurs de 2 points de quoi
après janvier 2021 donc ça a pris un peu
de temps et c'est parce qu'il ya
toujours des discussions ici sur le fait
que qu'ovide soit
aéroportée ce qui est un peu étrange
alors que ça a été admis par la majorité
de la police scientifique sans aucun
doute merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage l'oni besançon sur la
situation en suède aujourd'hui je
rappelle vous êtes chercheur en datation